ALOK JAIN: Hello and welcome
to What's New in Anthos.
In this session, we will go
over exciting new additions
to Anthos, which will
make it even more easier
for you to manage and secure
your multi-cloud and hybrid
applications.
We have been working hard
to add more features,
expand reach, and simplify
the experiences to make Anthos
the best application
modernization platform.
I'm Alok Jain.
And I lead Product Management
for Anthos at Google.
Joining us in this session
is my colleague Lisa Shen.
LISA SHEN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Lisa Shen.
And I am a Google
Cloud product manager.
ALOK JAIN: Before
we dive deep, here's
a quick introduction for
those who are new to Anthos.
Let's go back a few years.
We created Kubernetes
to maximize
productivity of our own
developers at Google.
And then we open sourced it to
help others achieve the same.
To make Kubernetes
production-ready,
we created Google
Kubernetes Engine--
or GKE, as we call it--
the best way to
consume Kubernetes
as a reliable, secure,
and fully-managed service.
In 2019, we introduced Anthos,
a managed platform designed
to simplify the
management of Kubernetes
cluster or any public
or private cloud
by extending a GKE-like
experience along with our best
open source frameworks.
Anthos extends Google
engineering practices
to your environment, so that you
can modernize your apps faster
and establish operational
consistency across them
from a single pane of glass.
It helps you minimize
operational overhead
as you scale your infrastructure
and helps you reduce
the total cost of ownership.
Containerization offers a common
application packaging format
across different
infrastructure types.
And Kubernetes offers consistent
APIs and control mechanisms,
and thus can be used for
application deployments
on your existing
virtual machines,
or bare metal servers, or even
on other public clouds like AWS
and Azure--
besides Google Cloud.
Anthos is made up of
a few core components.
Infrastructure
management provides
a reliable and efficient
way to deploy and run
containers and manage them
across any environment.
Next is application
service management--
it provides managed service mesh
to connect, manage, and secure
containers.
We extend the
capabilities of Anthos
to run serverless
applications as well.
It also has a wide selection of
production-related development
stacks and services.
Operation management is
an integrated logging
and monitoring service for
your container, services,
and applications.
Policy management and
security management
are central to manage
configuration and security
policies across your fleet.
And it helps you reduce
your operational cost--
at the same time, enforce
security posture that's
right for your applications.
With that, we are now
ready to jump right
in and talk about the new and
exciting additions to Anthos.
Anthos MultiCloud allows
container orchestration
standardization across clouds
via a new managed service.
With this new
service, we've also
added support for
Anthos and Azure.
Both of these are in
preview with GA coming right
around the corner.
So now you can deploy
Google Kubernetes clusters
with GCP, AWS, and Azure
directly from Google Cloud.
You can control all cluster
lifecycle operations centrally.
You can review system
and application logs
and monitor clusters
across all clouds
through a single pane of glass.
Cluster lifecycle
operations can be controlled
via G. Cloud, API, or Terraform,
allowing for a completely
automated workflow.
As a result, you get
consistent, unified,
and secure cluster and
container management
on a cloud of your choice.
In addition to centralized
logging and monitoring,
you benefit from
our connect gateway,
which allows for Google Cloud
to be the central access
point for each cluster.
We'll talk more
about it in a minute.
After you've deployed Kubernetes
fabric in your environment,
the next step is to deploy
cluster-level configuration
policy.
And finally, application specs--
choosing Anthos configuration
management service,
you can send GKE
and non-GKE cluster
to a Git repo that
defines the guardrails
for your organization.
The repo can include config
maps, network policies,
SRE agents, and so on.
Policy configurations can
also be located in the repo
to enforce best practices
or custom rules set
by your organization.
For example, you can
set policies to actively
block non-compliant
API requests or simply
to audit the configuration
of your clusters
and report violations,
such as applications
without proper labels.
Configuration specs
can be applied
to all clusters or just a subset
using Cluster Selector Object.
Any changes to the
config in the repo
will be observed
automatically by the cluster.
And besides GKE, Anthos supports
CMC of confirmed Kubernetes
clusters like AKS or EKS,
giving you the option
to keep your application running
on your favorite Kubernetes
and still take advantage
of Anthos services.
Next is Anthos on bare metal.
It lets you deploy
Kubernetes clusters directly
on your own servers, giving
you the best performance
and flexibility options.
You have direct control over
the application scale, security,
network latency by running
containerized application
on GKE and benefit from Anthos
components running locally.
We have made a number
of announcements
recently to Anthos
on bare metal,
such as providing Containerd
as a default runtime,
adding registry
building that helps
you insulate from any service
outages over the network
and helps improve the security.
It will also reduce
minimum system requirement
for running Anthos on bare metal
by over 50% for edge use cases.
Now you will only need
one of the two PCPUs
and only four
gigabytes of memory
to run Anthos on bare metal.
That means more
compute and more memory
available for your applications.
It reduces the overall TCO.
And you have many edge locations
with a small footprint.
Anthos on bare metal brings
Google Kubernetes Engine
to optimized centers with broad
support for vSphere platforms,
including the latest
stable release 7.0.
We have rolled out a number
of features on Anthos VMware
this year.
For example, with the Cluster
Backup and Restore feature,
you can now set up
admin plus 10 backups
to perform automatically before
and after cluster creation
or upgrade for user
and admin clusters.
You can also perform
an on-demand backup
whenever you deem it necessary.
Another feature is User
Cluster Autoscaling,
which resizes the
number of nodes
in a given node pool based
on demand of your workloads.
You don't need to manually
add or remove nodes or even
overprovision your node pools
to guarantee availability--
and thereby adding to the cost.
Instead, you can specify
a minimum and maximum size
for the node pole and the rest
is taken care automatically.
Last year, we announced support
for Windows server containers
on GCP, which lets you take
advantage of containers
without putting in
applications to darknet code
or rewriting them.
We have now enabled support
for Windows server container
and Anthos for VMware embedded
in your on-prem environment.
By running Windows and Linux
workloads side by side,
you get operational
consistency and efficiency.
There is no need to have
multiple teams specializing
in different
tooling or platforms
to manage different workloads.
Mixed workloads can be
configured on a single cluster
as well, giving you
even more flexibility.
The ability to manage policies
from a central control plane
further simplifies the
management experience,
while bin-packing multiple
Windows applications
drives better
resource utilization,
leading to infrastructure
and license cost savings.
We have recently made Anthos
Connect Gateway generally
available for our customers.
It provides a single
Google-hosted front load,
allowing for customers to
use their existing tooling
to effortlessly access
Anthos-connected clusters
running anywhere.
It solves key pain points we
have heard from many customers,
deploying on-prem, at the
edge, or even on other clouds.
Accessing Kubernetes
clusters can be a challenge.
And they often resort to
using jump hosts or VPNs
to these clusters.
Connect Gateway simplifies
the connectivity challenge
by using the same infrastructure
that powers existing connected
Anthos UIs. The service
authenticates and authorizes
GCP users and forwards their
request to the Connect agent
running in the cluster, and
ultimately, the cluster's
Kubernetes API server.
As a result, you get a
consistent and secure way
to use your existing
Kubernetes tooling
to perform common operations
against any fleet-registered
Kubernetes cluster.
A key building block for Anthos
infrastructure management
is our software-defined
networking,
as the capabilities in Anthos
extend the full networking
stack from layer 2 to layer 7.
And it's built on
best-in-class Kubernetes
open-source infrastructure.
We have extended
the capabilities
with innovations such as
node network firewalls
to protect workload at
infrastructure level.
Load balancing for Kubernetes
workload is bundled
in by taking in solutions
like MetalLB and extending it
for layer 4 /
layer 7 use cases ,
as well as integrating
BJP support into it.
We also enable
connectivity workloads
across hybrid environments with
easy-to-deploy VPN solution
and provide consistent
observability and affordability
tools.
There are two important
features that we
have introduced in Anthos
networking stack this year.
Anthos Dataplane v2 is optimized
for Kubernetes networking.
It is an opinionated
data plane that
leverages Cilium, an
open-source project that
makes the Linux kernels
Kubernetes-aware using AVP app.
It delivers a unified
user experience
for configurations,
deployments, and monitoring
of networking features across
Google Cloud, hybrid, and even
other cloud environments.
It makes parts.
The first cluster is
a networking ecosystem
with better performance
and visibility.
Another key feature is
Anthos networking gateway,
which provides a number
of advanced networking
features for hybrid and
multicloud environments.
For example, Egress
NAT enables you
to have a deterministic
IP for egress traffic
with namespace and
level granularity.
With multi-cluster
connectivity, you
get direct part reachability
between environments.
Well, I hope you're as
excited about these additions
as we are.
And wait, we have a
lot more to talk about.
I'll invite Lisa to share
more exciting capabilities
that we've added to Anthos.
LISA SHEN: Thank you, Alok.
Now let's take a look at Anthos
Configuration Management.
It enables you to automatically
deploy shared environment
configurations and enforce
approved security policies
across Kubernetes clusters
on premises, on GKE,
and in your other
public cloud platforms.
As part of Anthos
Configuration Management,
we have recently announced
a new feature available
called Config Controller,
a hosted service
to provision and orchestrate
Google Cloud resources.
The service offers
an API endpoint
that can provision
and orchestrate
more than 120 Google
Cloud resources
the same way it manages
Kubernetes resources,
with continuous monitoring
and self healing.
As a hosted service,
you don't have
to install or manage the
components of the Config
Controller or be an expert in
Kubernetes resource management,
because Google Cloud
will manage them for you.
Config Controller
provisions infrastructure,
applications, and
cloud services,
configs them to meet
your desired intent,
and monitors them for
the configuration Git.
Config changes are as
easy as a Git push,
and can be easily integrated
with your development
workflows.
Another exciting new feature
we've introduced this year
is the ACM Multi-Repo Support.
Enabling Multi-Repo mode
lets you sync configurations
from multiple repositories
to the same set of clusters.
An example is shown
in the diagram here.
The platform admin manages
the centralized infrastructure
for the organization
and enforces policies
on the cluster and on all
namespaces in the org.
The application developers who
are responsible for managing
live deployments
apply configurations
to applications in the
namespaces they work on.
The Multi-Repo feature decouples
the config deployment lifecycle
for different teams.
It provides you with more
autonomy and flexibility.
And you get to choose where
you want to place the repo
and how to structure it.
Microservice architectures
present numerous benefits
but also introduce challenges
like added complexity
and fragmentation for
different workloads.
Anthos Service Mesh, which is
a Google fully managed service,
simplifies service
delivery across the board,
from traffic management and
mesh telemetry to security
and communications between
different services.
We have many exciting new
features rolled out in ASM
this year.
And all of these are Anthos
value-add over the Istio
open source project.
With the managed ASM
control plan on GCP,
Google is responsible for the
availability, scalability,
and the security of
the control plane.
We also have managed
certification on GCP
and managed proxy updates
based on the release channels.
Both SRE dashboard with
service-level objectives
and the Security
Insights dashboard
are available to give
you in-depth visibility
into the application services.
With the application
Security Insights dashboard,
you will have a 360-degree
view of workload security.
You get a summary of the
security configuration
with the workload drilldown
view to troubleshoot
security issues.
In addition, you can now
add Google Compute Engine
VMs in managed instance
groups to a service mesh.
You'll get the same
observability, telemetry,
and security
capabilities as you would
get from running
services on Anthos GKE
clusters in the mesh.
Anthos Identity Service is an
authentication proxy for Anthos
that enables customers
to authenticate
their users to
Anthos environment
using their existing
identity solutions.
AIS simplifies
identity management
across hybrid and
multicloud deployments
by providing a common
authentication abstraction
layer for all the
Anthos environments.
As a result, you can leverage
your existing identity
investment with Anthos
using standard identity
protocols such as LDAP or
OIDC, or you can consistently
apply your policies
across the environments.
It simplifies your
cross-environment workload
migration.
Anthos Workload Identity feature
enables Kubernetes workload
hosted on any cluster
to authenticate
to Google Cloud or other
services in a consistent way.
We have extended GKE
workload identity
concept to Anthos platforms
on-prem and in multiclouds.
The Workload Identity
Federation feature
eliminates the need for
long-lead credentials
and replaces them with
short-lead, autorotated
credentials.
It enables consistent
authentication
across all the clusters.
The feature not only helps
application developers
to connect applications to
essential services easier,
but also helps
the platform admin
to maintain the governance
across the clusters.
On the application
management side,
I'm very excited that we
will have Anthos Hybrid
CI/CD available for public
preview in November this year.
Built on top of the
existing Google Cloud
Build and the Google
Cloud Deploy solution,
Anthos Hybrid CI/CD will allow
customers to build and deploy
containerized
applications seamlessly
to hybrid and multicloud
environments using
a single control plane.
Hybrid Cloud on-cluster
CI/CD is ideal for customers
that are prohibited from
connecting their source control
or artifact repos to GCP due
to organizational, or network,
or security requirements.
More specifically, this
will allow customers
to run CI/CD workloads
with their private network
with simplified network
configurations that don't
rely upon network peering.
In addition, the on-cluster
CI/CD also reduces the latency
for accessing local resources.
Another popular tool included
in the Anthos product
is Migrate for Anthos and GKE.
Migrate for Anthos
and GKE intelligently
extracts, migrates,
and modernizes
applications to run natively
on containers in GKE and Anthos
clusters.
It makes it easy and
fast to modernize
traditional applications
away from virtual machines
and into native containers.
You can migrate VMs running
on VMware, AWS, or Azure
into containers managed
by Anthos in real time
and capitalize on increased
resource utilization, unified
logging and monitoring, and
modern application lifecycle
management tools.
A recent feature
that we've introduced
is called the Migrate
Fit Assessment
Tool, which helps customers
discover their inventory
and assess fit for
containerization.
It replaces the existing
Migrate Discovery Tool
and it runs completely
disconnected from the internet.
In addition, Migrate
for Anthos and GKE
now supports enhanced
container runtimes
such as Anthos Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is a managed
compute platform
that enables you to run
stateless containers that
are invocable by web
request or Pub/Sub events.
The enhancements let you
deploy your migrate container
workloads on Cloud Run.
You can learn more about
Anthos via Google Cloud Product
website or explore our powerful
multi-cluster Kubernetes
management features with
the Anthos sample deployment
tutorial.
When you are ready, be sure
to schedule your application
assessment workshop
with your Google team
to begin planning your
application modernization
journey.
Thank you for watching the show.
And I hope you have a great day.
ALOK JAIN: Thanks, Lisa.
And thank you, everyone,
for being with us
on What's New With Anthos.
We hope you enjoy the rest
of the Google Next 2021.